-House GOP leader Kevin McCarthy
threw a nearly nine-hour
tantrum on the House floor
as Democrats passed their
signature social spending bill.
Meanwhile, one Republican
senator continued to spread
Trump's big lie
about the election
and another accused a Biden
nominee of being a communist.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
There was a temptation
during his presidency
to believe that Donald Trump
and the fringe movement
of goons and weirdos
who supported him
were not necessarily the core
of the modern GOP,
that once Trump
faded away,
the party would return
to some semblance of normalcy.
But over and over, Republicans
keep proving how naive and wrong
that assumption was.
And look, I get it.
I think lots of people
were hoping
this would be
a Beetlejuice situation
where we could just say
his name three times
and he would disappear
into that waiting room
where he'd finally look
like he fits in.
"We love shrunken head guy,
don't we, folks?
We don't talk about him enough.
regularly about it.
Love his tiny head.
And of course, what a seat next
to the great Geena Davis,
League of Their Own'?
What a film. What a film.
They say there's no crying
in baseball,
but when Kit plowed into Dottie
and she dropped the ball,
I'll admit I had a little bit
of dust in my eye."
Anyhow...
By the way, we're trying
a new transitional word today
instead of "anyway."
Are you delivering a comedic
digest of the day's news?
Did you get stuck
in a nonsensical tangent and
need a way back to the politics
but used "anyway"
too many times?
Try anyhow "anyhow."
[ Chime dings ]
Anyhow, Trump did not disappear,
and even if he did,
the brand of politics
he represented is very much
alive and well within the GOP
and not just among some
obscure lunatics in the House.
Texas Senator Ted Cruz
was just on CBS this weekend,
continuing to spread
the big lie
that there was widespread
fraud in the 2020 election
and defend his role in trying
to overturn the results
on January 6th.
-I brought together a group
of 11 senators,
and we objected to call for
a for an electoral commission
to review the claims of voter
fraud and to assess
and make a determination
to consider the evidence,
which I think would have been
much better for our democracy
because we right now have a
substantial chunk of our country
that has real doubts about
the integrity of the election.
And if we had had
a credible electoral commission
do an emergency audit,
it would have enhanced
faith in democracy.
But instead, Democrats
and a lot of the press
decided to just engage
in incendiary rhetoric
rather than acknowledge
voter fraud is real.
It is a problem...
-Well, do you have --
-...and the allegations
of voter fraud
needed to be examined
on the merits.
-Alright, first of all,
over 60 cases
did examine the evidence,
and not one found any merit
in any of Trump's claims.
That includes judges
appointed by Trump
and the GOP-dominated
Supreme Court.
You think a judge appointed
by Trump himself
would turn down
the opportunity to help out?
They were probably getting
nonstop texts from him
begging for help
like an ex who won't go away.
Seriously, did you forget
about all that?
I mean, how could you?
Rudy Giuliani is probably
still standing outside
the Supreme Court,
banging on the front door
like a guy who just got evicted
from his apartment
for hoarding cats.
"Hey, those aren't my pets.
Those are my law partners.
You can't do this to
Whiskers, Whiskers,
Giuliani and Klein."
And look,
it's not like Republicans
stopped looking for voter fraud
after Biden's election
was certified.
CNN reported back in October
that a week after the 2020
election, Texas Lt. Governor
Dan Patrick announced
that he was offering up
to $1 million to incentivize,
encourage, and reward people
to come forward
and report voter fraud.
Nearly a year later,
Patrick, a Republican,
has paid out his first reward
$25,000 to a Democrat
in Pennsylvania
who reported a Republican
who, after voting once,
attempted to vote
a second time as his son.
That's right,
Patrick had to pay the reward
to a registered Democrat
who reported a Republican
that was 72 years old
for trying to vote
a second time as a son.
How does a 72-ear-old man
try and vote as his son?
Does he put on a dark baseball
hat and Ray Ban sunglasses?
I don't know. Let's take
a look at the article.
Oh, that is what he did.
Alright.
Probably made
a big show of it too.
"Voting for squares like my dad.
But for an election
this important,
I guess I can live
with being lame for once.
Where's the nearest
skateboard park?
I'm 51."
Anyhow...
[ Chime dings ]
...the GOP is still
very much devoted to Trump
and his brand,
whether it's spreading
the big lie
that the 2020 election
was stolen
or embodying the ideology
and performance of Trumpism,
the unhinged
conspiracy mongering
and dark implications
of a hidden plot
or sinister enemies
around every corner.
In fact, the GOP is so morally
and intellectually bankrupt,
they've circled all the way back
to accusing people
of being secret communists,
Joe McCarthy style.
-An outrageous turn during
an already contentious
confirmation hearing Thursday,
Republican Senator
John Kennedy of Louisiana
suggesting the nominee
who grew up in a country
that was still under
Soviet Union control
might still support
communist policy.
Saule Omarova
is President Biden's pick
to be Comptroller
of the Currency.
-I don't mean any disrespect.
I don't know whether to call you
professor or comrade.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Senator...
...I'm not a communist.
I do not subscribe
to that ideology.
I could not choose
where I was born.
My family suffered
under the communist regime.
I came to this country.
I'm proud to be an American,
and this is why
I'm here today, Senator.
-That's Louisiana
Senator John Kennedy,
who went to Oxford
and used to be a Democrat,
but has since adopted
the voice and mannerisms
of a slow-talking,
suspender-wearing alligator
from a Disney movie
who threatens to drain the bayou
and replace it
with a shopping mall.
"Well, what have we got here?
This swamp will make
a mighty fine Chick-Fil-A
if I do say so myself."
Honestly, you know
you've taken a real villain turn
when someone gasps off camera
and reacts to your line
of questioning the way soap
opera characters react
when an evil twin shows up.
"Oh, my goodness, it's...
the evil John Kennedy."
[ Thunder booming ]
[ Laughter ]
Worst part of my day today --
Wally -- the ol' cue card
Wally goes,
"Hey, are you going to be okay
remembering
the evil John Kennedy?
You need a second set of cards
over the other camera?"
I'm fine, bro.
Crushed it.
-Yeah, you did good.
You did good.
[ Laughter ]
-And by the way,
a fellow senator,
Democrat Tina Smith
of Minnesota,
confirmed that it was her
who said,
"Oh, my goodness" off camera,
writing on Twitter,
"That person off camera is me
and what I was really thinking
was "holy [bleep]."
Which is appropriate
because the rest of Kennedy's
questions were also
holy [bleep].
For example,
earlier in that same exchange,
Kennedy asked her
if she had formally resigned
from a mandatory
school organization
in a country
that no longer exists.
-You used to be a member
of a group
called the Young Communist,
didn't you?
-Senator, are you referring
to my membership
in the Youth
Communist Organization
while I was growing up
in the Soviet Union?
-I don't know. I just wanted
to ask you that question.
-Everybody in that country
was a member of the Komsomol,
which was the communist
youth organization.
-So you were -- were a member?
-That was a part of
normal progress in school.
-Did you -- Have you resigned?
-From the...?
-From the Young Communists?
-You grow out of it with age
automatically.
-Did you -- Did you send them
a letter, though, resigning?
-Senator, this was many,
many years ago.
As far as I remember
how the Soviet Union worked
was at a certain age,
you automatically stop
being a member.
-Could you look at your records
and see if you can find a copy?
-I'm sorry.
Do you think schoolchildren
keep records that include copies
of letters they sent?
If they did, I'd still
have all the letters I sent
Wendy Hughes asking her
what Aaron Matthews had
that I didn't, and even worse,
I'd have copies of her response.
But, sure, she should write
a formal letter of resignation
to a country
that no longer exists.
While she's doing that,
maybe you can write a letter
resigning from,
I don't know, Boss Hogg's gang?
This is what the unhinged
Republican Party is now.
You can see the same
hysterical performance last week
from House GOP
leader Kevin McCarthy,
who staged a nearly nine-hour
meltdown on the House floor
over the Democrat's
social spending bill,
which, among other
radical socialist ideas,
provides funding
for universal pre-K,
extends the new child
tax credit mandates,
paid family leave,
and expands Medicare
to include hearing aids.
All that stuff is apparently
so unacceptable to McCarthy,
he lost his mind in a tantrum
that went past 5:00 a.m.
while being heckled by Democrats
from the back row.
-He delayed that vote
with a long,
very long, super long speech.
It lasted a record-breaking
eight hours and 32 minutes.
-This is the single most
reckless and irresponsible
spending bill
in our nation's history.
I can look anywhere I want,
Mr. Speaker.
Mr. Speaker,
I cannot believe the amount
of control one party rule wants.
They now want to dictate
to a member on the floor
of where I can look?
You ever eaten
one of these baby carrots?
I'll lead you
in a little secret.
There's no such thing.
They're just big carrots.
They chop them, they charge
you more, and you buy them.
I have a friend
who serves in the Senate.
Right before COVID,
he was on a [indistinct]
with other senators,
and he was sitting
and having a communication --
maybe you've experienced
this as well --
with a military general
in the Chinese Communist Army.
You know what General
said to him?
"America, you're weak."
-McCarthy's got the amped-up
energy of a fifth grader
telling you about a classmate.
"I have a friend,
and his name is Timmy,
and he went to the zoo
and met a donkey
and the donkey took a big poop
and it was so funny."
Seriously, what was the point
of that story?
I feel like I zoned out during
an anecdote at a dinner party,
and now I have to catch up
to figure out what the hell
he's talking about.
"Uh-huh? Oh, yeah.
Wow, so they kicked you out
for having too many cats?"
"And now I have no one
to help me type up my lawsuits.
They even took Klein."
Is this true about the baby
carrots
are just big carrots
they cut up?
[ Laughter ]
What about baby corn?
Seems like it should be
consistent
across all the vegetables.
[Bleep] hell of a way
to find out.
That's all I'll say.
The only fun anyone got out of
this demented spectacle
was getting the chance
to heckle McCarthy,
like when Ohio
Congressman Tim Ryan
yelled at him from the back,
"Keep going,
no one's listening."
And then yesterday,
McCarthy went on to Fox News's
most deranged shows
with Maria Bartiromo
to be congratulated
for going off the deep end
while whining about Democrats
interrupting him.
-Congratulations.
How is your voice doing after
eight and a half hours speaking?
-You know, my voice
is still strong
because it's still strong
for the American people.
You know, when I went
to the floor,
I had no idea
we would speak that long.
It wasn't about breaking
the record.
It was about
breaking down this bill
and the amount of heckling
that they would try to do
to stop me from
being able to talk.
-"I never thought I'd talk
that long,
but right before
I went on the floor,
I got this very jarring news
about baby carrots."
[ Laughter ]
This guy is such a goober.
He sounds like
a substitute teacher
complaining to the principal
that his high school class
won't stop chucking things
at him.
"I got hit with
a spit ball, a paper airplane,
and fully knocked out
with a stapler.
And then when I came to,
that changed
my name of the chalkboard
to Mr. McFarty."
Republican party
is just as unhinged
as it was during the Trump
years, if not more so.
They're fully devoted
to both Trump
the man and the performance
of Trumpism,
whether it's lying
about the election,
accusing people
of being secret communists,
or staging deranged meltdowns
on the House floor.
It reminds me
of something my very real
and totally not
imaginary friend once told me.
He said, "Kevin McCarthy..."
-You're weak.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over two million
meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.